everyone knows about Elon musk's
company's Tesla and SpaceX but few know
that he also co-founded open AI in the
few short years of its existence openai
has become one of the world's leading
artificial intelligence research Labs it
ended 2022 with a bang as millions of
people signed up for chat GPT its
question and answer computer program is
so popular that some schools have banned
it to prevent students from cheating it
took just one second to write me a poem
about strawberry cheesecake in the tone
of Shakespeare another open AI tool
generates art I typed a few words and
Dolly to produced these beautiful
designs open ai's futuristic research
laboratory is housed in this historic
building in San Francisco it's a small
company with only around 400 employees
but it's making huge advances in AI
everything it's working on involves
mimicking human intelligence by
analyzing tremendous amounts of data on
the internet the sheer amount of
computing required is incredibly
expensive a professor in the University
of Maryland's computer science
department estimates chat gbt costs a
hundred thousand dollars a day to run
and some feel that estimate is far too
low AI has been toted as a next big
thing for a while now but it wasn't
until recently that the general public
began taking it seriously open AI was
only founded in 2015 as a non-profit
platform by musk and CEO Sam Altman I
think that AI will be a technological
Revolution on the scale of the
Agricultural the industrial the computer
Revolution before starting open AI
Altman was the president of the Venture
Capital company Y combinator which
helped launch Airbnb Reddit twitch and
many more
Altman and musk teamed up with legendary
Silicon Valley investor Peter Thiel and
Linkedin co-founder Reed Hoffman and
pledged 1 billion toward the project
open ai's current investors include
Microsoft which is reportedly now
investing 10 billion into chat GPT
Microsoft says it will roll out chat gbt
on its own AI service Azure open AI
companies like Al Jazeera use Azure for
translation services could chat gbt
breathe life into Microsoft's struggling
search engine Bing and give Google a run
for its money could it replace
traditional search engines altogether
Google CEO Sunder pachai is supposedly
taking the threat seriously he has
reportedly told staff to focus urgently
on developing AI products Google
researchers revealed they were able to
transform a few still images into a 3D
reconstruction of a scene
Google is competing against a young and
Nimble company this is what the first
day at the office looked like in early
2016. pretty Bare Bones the small team
has come a long way but there's still a
long way to go Chachi PT sometimes gives
answers that are misleading or downright
wrong I asked it to solve this riddle
Timothy's mom has four Sons their names
are north south and east what's the name
of the fourth sun chatgpt says it's West
the answer is Timothy Altman warns that
it's a mistake to be rely on it for
anything important right now but he does
have high hopes and says future systems
will make chat GPT look like a boring
toy the changes are coming fast open
ai's president tweeted 2023 will make
2022 look like a sleepy year for AI
advancement in adoption musk responded
to Greg Brockman with a single word
yikes there's a lot packed into that
word Musk has warned about the dangers
of AI for years equating it to summoning
the demon here's what he told CNBC in
2014. I'd like to just keep an eye on
what's going on with artificial
intelligence I think there's potentially
potentially a dangerous outcome there
and we need to dangerous
potentially yes I mean there's been
movies about this you know like
Terminator movies the movie Terminator
they didn't expect
you know some sort of terminator-like
outcome while musk may be worried about
advances in technology ironically his
companies rely on AI Tesla is inching
toward the full self-driving Finish Line
thanks to AI musk consists Tesla's most
valuable product ever could be its AI
powered bot his chip company neurolink
wants to sync the brain with artificial
intelligence musk resigned from the
board of open AI to avoid any future
conflicts because of Tesla's work in AI
he stayed on as a donor and investor he
insists he's making sure AI is used for
good not evil open ai's website states
that its mission is to ensure that
artificial general intelligence benefits
all of humanity artificial general
intelligence is the ability to learn any
task that a human can so that faced with
an unfamiliar task an AGI system can
still figure out what to do so what's in
store for this year hey Alexa what will
happened in 2023 sorry I can't predict
the future maybe in the future AI
personal assistance will be a lot
smarter one prediction is that AI will
replace a lot of jobs artists are
already fearing for their livelihoods
this AI generated artwork even won an
art competition in Colorado last year
however the world economic Forum
estimates AI will actually create
Millions more jobs than it destroys with
high demand for machine learning
Specialists and data analysts
as we look toward the future open ai's
next Generation version of chat GPT is
highly anticipated and could appear in
2023 and how about an AI that generates
3D models where you type in a few words
and the program creates what usually
takes animators hours to make openai
announced the 3D tool Point e in a
research paper last year it's still a
work in progress in 2023 could see
further developments
what open AI has shown is that a small
dedicated team can change the world
quickly even if the road ahead is
difficult
the CEO of open AI recently tweeted
about the importance of resilience
Altman wrote you're supposed to put your
life force into something and it's not
supposed to always be easy
in the future artificial intelligence
will at the very least make things look
easy
despite the economic meltdown we all
faced in 2022 it's clear there are still
Innovative companies on the rise and
while open AI is showing promise one
unicorn fintech startup is delivering
booming returns right now
Masterworks has unlocked the potential
of Contemporary Art a 1.7 trillion
dollar asset class that used to only be
available to billionaires with
Masterworks everyday investors can enter
the high-end Art Market without spending
Millions why art contemporary art has
outpaced the S P 500 by 131 over the
last 26 years while the markets were
getting crushed in 2022 Masterworks saw
11 artworks deliver returns to investors
in the tens of millions of dollars over
617 000 people have signed up for Mass
to work so far including many of my
viewers and you can sign up now to
create a free no obligation account at
the link in my desk description